I'm very delighted to have the
opportunity and actually the privilege
to introduce to you Anthony Jeanette oz
and i'm going to give his a little bit
about him because he's one of these
keepers really a special especially
trained but also a tremendous
perspective on the global crisis that
were they were discussing the summer his
degrees are in biology he graduated
magna laude from harvard college and
then took a master's in a PhD in biology
from princeton university but he moved
from what you typically consider to be a
biologist we were talking a little bit
today about natural historians and plant
identification he moved into
mathematical modeling and the ability to
make ecosystem assessments and that's
what he does without any peer that I
know he spent many many years in
managing science and policy research
programs with the Environmental
Protection Agency with the National
Aeronautics and Space Administration
which and his uh specialized as i said
on ecological topics environmental
issues as they relate for example to air
pollution effects on forests on climate
change impacts on land-use changes on
ecosystem modeling and the global carbon
cycle he was the lead author and
convener the climate change science
program synthesis and assessment product
and he's been involved in any number
more than i can count or he's led
several national and international
assessments on these topics so his
specialty is linking scientific
environmental economic and policy issues
into a more of a whole cloth perspective
for the consideration of very high level
policymakers he's recently been director
of the joint global change research
institute which is a joint venture
between Pacific Northwest National
Laboratory in the universe
Maryland and so he lives a few blocks
from the National Science Foundation in
Arlington and now is moving to Boston
which I'm happy for because it's a
little closer to me but Tony Janeiro's
has now been named the new director of a
center called the Frederick s party
center for the study of the longer-range
feature and he will he will be
presenting today some perspectives on
communicating successes and failures on
these assessments but he'll also be
clearly defining what he means by the
longer future and so I'd like you to
welcome Tony to our podium thank you for
being with us tonight Jim thank you I I
can see that you you've already set the
bar impossibly high if I going to do one
out of the two things that the gym is
indicated at least I'll be happy so let
me talk a little bit what I'd like to do
is talk about what has become sort of a
novel process in the communication of
science so this is not a strict science
talk about what do we know about global
changes in the environment and how well
do we know them and what do the models
say what's the empirical evidence what I
want to talk about instead is how we
communicate what we think we know in the
scientific community to a wide variety
of policy audiences and so well I
thought I would start by talking about
at least the kind of working definition
that I'm going to use for what
identifies a scientific assessment and
in this case we're talking about
processes that involve reviews of the
sunderland science by whole groups and
communities of experts it could be
across disciplines and in fact it is
across disciplines in many cases that
are consensus seeking processes where
the intent of the process is to try to
come to some consensus on the state of
knowledge about set of questions that
are particularly relevant to policy
issues that are commissioned
or overseen by the policy audiences
themselves whether it's countries or
states or other international
multinational institutions and that are
that are meant to address both our
knowledge and major uncertainties that
are perceived to be important for
policymaking and this really is in a
sense a novel way of communicating with
policy audiences for scientists and
academics and engineers of my generation
nobody nobody did this people people you
know would regularly do annotated
bibliographies they would do literature
reviews you know that they would they
would do these cons of reviews further
for our scholarly peers but but the
communication of what we know knew about
science to policy audiences was largely
the innocence was larger the province of
particular individuals who had a desire
or the opportunity to do that it wasn't
this sort of community process and
what's emerged since the really since
the mid-1980s is a whole new way
institutionally of communicating about
science to two audiences who are going
to make decisions in part on that
knowledge and so some of the questions
that I think are important to keep in
mind as we think about which of these
efforts in a sense succeed and which
fail is who Commission's the effort who
participates in the effort you know is
there a coherent policy driver is there
a coherent set of decisions or policies
that are under consideration is there a
receptive audience to the to the lessons
and the the knowledge and hopefully the
wisdom that emerges from from these
processes and how would we actually
identify success what's an appropriate
metric for success because what we'll
see is that there are lots of replicas
nation of processes that are perceived
to be successes and in some cases I will
argue are successful but they're not but
not always with the same end results and
so it's worth and it's then worth asking
why not so for discussion this evening
I'm going to do I'm going to share some
of my own experiences from working on
several international and and domestic
us scientific assessments a lot of this
work has had to do with climate change
but not all of it I'm going to share my
perceptions of the relative success of
these communications effort and discuss
with you at least my analysis of why
some have been more successful than
others and then at the end offers some
suggestions both topical suggestions for
how these assessments might change over
time and a couple of process suggestions
for how these assessments might change
over time so for international examples
i'm going to i'm going to focus on three
one is the Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change about which I'll talk a
great deal the one in the middle and I
guess I'll need to apologize for the
poor quality of that picture is actually
the millennium ecosystem assessment and
the third is an assessment called the
global biodiversity assessment and then
I will follow that with several examples
strictly from the US at the top is the
cover of the first US National Climate
Assessment of potential consequences of
climate variability and change on the
left is a more focused scientific
assessment on effects of climate change
on basically on natural resources
agriculture water resources land
resources biodiversity and in the bottom
right is the 2nd US National Climate
Assessment potential consequences of
climate change and I'm going to say
something about each of these examples
about how they were commissioned to
serve how they came into being what was
their rationale what was the reception
to that
and in a sense have they been were they
successful in their goals or not and so
doing I think one of the points that I
really want to emphasize is that this
type of scientific assessment this type
of community process is a communications
exercise the criticism which you will
hear in which you'll read that science
is not advanced by processes like the
IPCC that they don't push the frontiers
of knowledge is in my view completely
irrelevant these processes are not meant
to do that they are meant to seek
consensus they're not about blazing new
trails they're not about the sort of
individual creativity and diligence and
skill of the individual researchers or
laboratories they are or at least they
should be entirely about communicating
what we think we know as a community and
the strength of our strength or weakness
of our consensus communicating that to
fundamentally non-scientific policy
audiences who care about that because
this scientific knowledge is a part of
is a part of their decision making
process and so in my view the scientific
assessments should be judged as
communications exercises which is not
actually always appreciated by the
participants the because when you get
into kind of when you're in the mix of
one of these things you really do want
to do the best job you can at
summarizing and synthesizing the
underlying science and it's easy to lose
track of who you're doing this for so 11
interesting question is should they if
they're judged as communications
exercises should they be judged by the
actual policy outcomes that either
result or in some cases don't result
from the effort and I will argue that
that they should not that the that the
primary criterion for success is the
acceptance of the process by policy
audiences
and not necessarily whether or not a
particular policy decision or has been
made or a particular policy direction
has been established the former the
acceptance of the process of and the
credibility of the process is clearly
under control of both the participants
in the audience for scientific
assessments the latter what decisions
actually end up getting made or which
directions end up getting getting put in
place is a function of many different
factors of which the scientific
assessment is just one if it's a
function also of economics it's a
function of equity it's a function of in
some cases the sort of the political
economy of the decisions it's a function
of many things of which scientific
information is but one element so I
think it's important to keep in mind i
think that that what these assessments
are really about is this sort of
communication of knowledge not achieving
a particular scientific or a particular
policy result now in many ways but the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change ipcc has been thought of in a
sense as the gold standard of these
kinds of processes particularly in an
international context to be fair IPCC
was really built in a sense on the
previous model of the stratospheric
ozone assessment which was the
scientific input under the auspices of
the world meteorological organization
was the scientific input to the process
that led to the Montreal Protocol and in
fact did lead to significant policy
change that is the banning of
chlorofluorocarbons from general use
because of their effect on the ozone
layer IPCC on the other hand is a big
sprawling assessment the ranges from the
from the the causes of change in the
climate system to the degree of
detection
changes in the climate system the
attribution of human influence on the
physical climate system moving to the
consequences of those changes both
physical consequences on natural
resources and agriculture on ecosystems
on water resources to increasingly to
consequences on economic systems and
social social systems on settlements and
in the last round of IPCC beginning to
extend to the consequences of changes in
the physical climate system on the
prospects for development and continued
economic development of social
development around the world and the
third part of IPCC is really dedicated
to what do what can be done and in
particular what can be done to mitigate
that is to reduce emissions of
greenhouse gases what are possible
technological choices what are different
potential scenarios future conditions
what are different what are the
implications of different energy choices
and so forth and it's clean this entire
effort is in fact clearly not
prescribing policies the country should
take but is trying to trying to analyze
the suite of of potential futures their
ramifications for both physical systems
and social and economic systems in a
sense to illuminate the debate that the
countries have now undertaken in this
very long convention process over
multiple decades the effort involved in
this assessment or in this assessment
process is uh is enormous it's it's it's
an enormous effort both on the part of
the government's that sponsor it and
then in a sense run it
an enormous effort on the part of the
scientific communities who participate
literally thousands of scientists scores
of governments on both periodic full
assessments we're now working on the on
a r5 on the fifth full IPCC assessment
for all three primary working groups the
and a whole range of special reports
which were not that's part not part of
the initial vision of IPCC but grew up
over time because it was literally not
possible for this every five year
scientific synthesis to address
particular issues on that the country's
thought they needed a particular handle
on quickly and so now we're in this mode
that IPCC has effectively become a
full-time assessment process with the
full review causes consequences
mitigation about every five or six years
but in the in what were we might
euphemistically think of as the off
years a series of special reports on
particular topics driven by interest
from the participating governments so in
fact last year we had the publication of
the special report on extremes in
previous years we've had special reports
on emission scenarios special reports on
aviation special reports on land cover
land-use change in forestry and a whole
host of particular topics that have
followed the same model but have not
delved into all of the ramifications is
it successful is the IPCC successful and
I would argue that by my by my criterion
the answer is clearly yes the reports
themselves whether it's a special
reports or the big syntheses are always
an important part of international
policy discussions they're always an
important part of national policy
discussions because in
fact in large part because they're
perceived to be credible statements of
what's known and not know they become
less successful when that credit when
that credibility for whatever reason is
tarnished whether that's errors which
which you know not surprisingly creep
into do creep into the system or whether
it's the perception that IPCC might or
the scientists involved in it might be
following their own their own agendas so
there are weaknesses in the system for
all that I would argue that it is by and
large are in fact really a great success
it can't be relevant to all the possible
approaches to policymaking it's just
it's just not feasible to do
particularly it's not feasible for a
huge international effort like IPCC to
deal with the intricacies of national
policy making or regional policy making
in all of the countries um in all of the
parts of the world that it is meant to
address it's meant to be a global
process it's meant to be a truly
international process there is simply no
way that this process the process of
this scope can deal with every sort of
in a sense every possible policy
scenario that an individual country
might undertake on the other hand it
still addresses a fairly clear policy
issue both in terms of mitigation
choices perhaps clearer in terms of
mitigation choices than in adaptation
choices but there is a coherence to the
to the debate that IPCC is seeking to
inform IPCC changes directions slowly it
is still sort of slowly approaching the
topics of adaptation of the interaction
of the climate system with other global
changes with biodiversity changes or
with food security issues or with
development issues for example there's
possibly an under appreciation of the
importance of regional changes and
issues of vulnerability and resilience
in fact the chapter that I'm leading a
chapter in
working group 2 of IPCC which is the
working group on on consequences and
adaptation now which is in the whole
chapter is entitled regional context
this chapter has never existed before in
previous working group two documents and
I think that's a reflection of the fact
that that the agenda can change and the
the perceived policy issues that IPCC
responds to change but they change
slowly over time it's still largely
focused on sort of average results and
mean results and has difficulty
assessing extremes in part because the
process is highly dependent on modeling
and it's much more difficult to model
the variability in systems than it is
changes in mean state but it's also
because it wrestles with how one talks
about the probability or risk of extreme
events in a highly polarized topic and
not then be accused of cherry-picking or
fear mongering and in fact in some sense
quite unlike the stratospheric ozone
assessment in which the private sector
and scientists in the private sector and
engineers in the private sector were
extremely important contributors IPCC
has not been a welcoming environment for
the private sector enlarged again in
large part because there is a perception
that it's much more of an adversarial
relationship with with large firms in
the private sector regardless of whether
this is the desire of individuals I
think this is sort of the framing within
which um this has been done
we could contrast this for example with
the millennium ecosystem assessment and
and there are some interesting contrast
so the millennium ecosystem assessment
was really set up in large part to
understand whether or not the services
that we derived from ecosystems the
regulation of water supply of water
quality the influence of ecosystems on
air quality the maintenance of soil
fertility in a sense all of the
functions that we depend on for human
well-being the extraction of fiber of
food whether some of which are priced
many of which are not priced but we
depend on them anyway so this assessment
was really set up to understand whether
these services are being sustainably
managed over time or whether we're in a
sense eating away at the Capitol the
millennium ecosystem assessment quite
unlike IPCC was not specifically
commissioned by the national governments
it really arose out of a out of a
combination of the scientific community
the international NGOs who essentially
went to the UN General Assembly and said
we want you to sponsor this we want you
to sanction this we think this is
important for everything from poverty
reduction to development concerns and it
should be which should be continent
coincident with with the goals and
ambitions of the General Assembly and in
fact the Kofi Anan agreed with that and
specifically called for the Millennium
ecosystems ecosystem assessment in the
UN General Assembly without a strong
base in any one particular national
government the range of potential
decisions is was extremely broad
compared to the climate issue so so now
the climate issue is you know I say
talk I was talking with with many of the
graduate students just an hour or so ago
about the incredible tangle and breadth
of the climate issue where really the
policy issues are too what are you going
to do about the energy economy of the
world which is much more complicated
than the Montreal Protocol but think
about this with respect to the
millennium ecosystem assessment and the
sustainability of ecosystems and all of
the sort of food and services that we
derived from them this ranges some
policy issues everything from food
security to trade issues to conservation
of wildlife and habitat to fisheries
management to sustainable development
and energy and climate it's it's just an
extraordinarily broad reach and a really
quite incoherent collection of different
policy actors and potential actions it
did introduce this unifying concept of
ecosystem services and the trade-offs
among services but it was I think rather
more difficult to make that connection
to particular kinds of decisions in
particular places you might ask what was
the reaction of governments and here I
think it was very considerably by where
you SAT the if you if your perspective
was simply from the US there was a
tremendous scientific reach of the
millennium assessment into the u.s.
scientific community but in the US
policy community I would I would have to
say that that the reach has been really
rather minimal outside of outside of
some decision-making bodies and agencies
in the conservation field but in the
Scandinavian countries on the other hand
who were very strong components and
contributors and participants in the MA
there was a much stronger reach and
a lot of this I think had to do with
individuals individuals who sat on the
board individuals who took it upon
themselves in a sense to be champions in
their country for the conclusions of the
of the millennium assessment and of the
process but it was very much a mixed a
mixed reaction as to whether or not the
conclusions from the millennium
assessment were in a sense taken up in
in policy discussions the third
international example that I want to
just touch on is the global biodiversity
assessment that was that nice sort of
blue cover on the on the bottom right
this is probably the best summary of
biodiversity science you never heard of
and and therein lies lies the tale I
think it had many of the same
operational features of IPCC and indeed
of the millennium ecosystem assessment
international participation broad
oversight consensus seeking activity a
very serious attempt to summarize and
communicate clearly through executive
summaries and summaries for policymakers
it was in almost entirely a creation of
the scientific community was not
commissioned by the government's either
national governments it wasn't actually
commissioned or requested by the
biodiversity convention itself it was a
self organized effort and the reception
in those policy making communities was
essentially no there's essentially no
take up of the of the messages and
conclusions and the process from the
global biodiversity assessment even
though the Secretariat of the of the
Convention and you nap as institutions
were strong supporters of the process so
there was a there was sort of an
institutional in a sense sort of
bureaucratic institutional by in by very
knowledgeable and influential people but
the the countries themselves or the
institution's themselves that had to
make a set of decisions um
czyli shrug this aside now Harley you
know I think this is partly a not
invented here type of syndrome but also
partly a lack of focus on the on the
particular questions that were
immediately relevant to policymaking you
would you would be hard-pressed to go
through the GBA and identify the set of
issues around which countries or large
institutions actually had to make
decisions whereas it's actually fairly
clear in IPCC and the climate issue what
types of decisions are at least on the
table to be made whether they get made
or not as a different is a different
talk but um but everybody understands i
think what what the the menu is not so
much for the global biodiversity
assessment so in summary if i look at
these international examples I at least
conclude several things and one is the
importance of in fact critical
importance of national audiences in
addition to the international bodies
even though these are global issues and
and international issues that
international governance by itself is
not sufficiently strong to to act as
sort of a take up for the for the
scientific assessment processes national
governments have to be part of this
process secondly is that the clarity of
the policy questions and issues in a
sense of coherence of those issues
matters tremendously you really do have
to understand what the menu of choices
is if you're going to try to inform that
discussion successfully third and this
is a point of similarity is that there
was tremendous support in each of these
efforts for summaries policymakers
summaries executive summaries and other
similar communications tools to this day
you can go to the Millennium assessment
website and download at least three or
four versions of the summary slides of
the conclusions of the assessment
they've you know in a sense
there is a long lasting information base
and conclusion based on which to build
and lastly I think there needs to be
recognition of the policy communities
that the assessments have value for them
there's some some sense of co-ownership
of the process so i want to i'm going to
switch directions a little bit now and
focus on some domestic examples of some
us examples and because these are
largely through my own sort of personal
lens and experience this is going to
focus a lot on climate change I'll talk
about the first and second National
Climate Assessment so I'm going to talk
a little bit about this interim
assessment of potential impacts and
natural resources and I'll just point
out that we're in the middle of now of
the third national climate assessment
and that's that's worth keeping in mind
so let me talk about the first National
Climate Assessment this was the the
cover that was on the top of that little
triangle of covers the need for a
national climate assessment is actually
written into the authorizing legislation
for the u.s. global change research
program which is the collection of
agencies who are charged with supporting
and stimulating research on on global
change it was a broad national effort it
focused on potential impacts of climate
change and climate variability it was
really no significant reference to
mitigation so it's quite unlike IPCC in
that respect where there's a whole
working group devoted to mitigation
issues this one the first US assessment
was really devoted to impacts a lot of
effort devoted to stakeholder
interaction and engagement again quite
unlike IPCC which is a creature both of
the sponsoring governments and of the
scientific community without really much
outreach into others into other
stakeholder communities the US National
Assessments on the other hand from this
very beginning for in large measure have
really emphasized the need
to understand the desires and
perspectives of a wide range of
stakeholder communities I think in part
in large part because they have been
focused on potential impacts in a large
number of different sectors there were a
large there were both regional and
sectoral studies that were done
specifically commissioned specifically
for the assessment and then a short
national summary but in addition to the
national summary there were well in
excess of 20 or 30 additional
publications on us on a set of 20
regional workshops that have been held
on particular technical issues on
sectoral issues and including a very
detailed national report that has all of
the details of the analyses in the data
that is I suspect only a handful of
graduate students have ever cracked open
but it's it's it was really quite an
extraordinary research resource as
opposed to an assessment for the for the
policy communities were we successful
and I use we in this case because I was
actually one of the co-chairs of this
effort the synthesis report was it was
leaked in draft form get enormous
attention in the press the there were
thousands of comments in peer review
which is not unusual on the but you know
for a hundred pay for roughly 100 125
page document I think we had a probably
about ten thousand comments each one of
which has to be responded to an archived
and sort of put into a permanent docket
sort of carefully documented responses
there were oversight committees that
made sure we had done an adequate job of
responding but the report itself the
national report itself was released the
week after the Al Gore george bush
presidential election and you might
remember that we were all a little bit
distracted from climate policy and
environmental policy at that time it was
not the first thing on anybody's mind
and in fact the new administration
actively suppress the report to the
extent that it at one point the agencies
were actually for the US science
agencies were forbidden from citing it
literally forbidden from citing it in
their research planning efforts and in
subsequent reports the its results on
the other hand were in fact highly
influential and reports that in the
National Academies and informally in the
agencies in informing and influencing
their research agendas of the major
scientific agencies on the other hand on
state and local levels many of the
studies and reports that went into the
national report were extremely
influential including particularly here
in New York where researchers here at
Columbia across the street at Barnard
were were key players and what was then
called the Metro East Coast study which
became a major part of the scientific
underpinning for the city's added
climate adaptation plans the same a
similar thing went on and in the New
England states in the Northeast states
were the regional reports on the on the
Northeast were highly influential in in
a sense sort of setting the scientific
atmosphere under which the reggie
program was developed same thing was
true in california so the influence of
this report and informing policy
decisions was very much a mixed bag i
would have to say that on the national
level it really didn't it really was in
a sense only influential on research
agendas
has it had very little influence if any
tangible influence on the on the policy
discussion right around that time on the
other hand on state local and regional
levels that that that process had very
much more influence over sometime the
receptivity to climate change scientific
assessments actually improved and during
the Bush administration that Global
Change Program commissioned a whole
series of individual scientific
assessment reports in part to fulfill
the requirements of their underlying
legislation in part because there was a
growing I think a growing appreciation
even in this very polarized political
environment that they're really did need
to be this underlying input of
scientific thinking in the case that
that I put up there again this was an
effort that I was one of the co-leads
for we this was one of about 20
different reports this one the one I
showed you focus particularly on the
influence of climate change on natural
resources and we know that this was in
influential with individual agencies
with USDA with the Department of
Interior agencies with EPA in USDA we
actually ended up having some very
serious discussions with the officials
in charge of the crop insurance programs
about you know were the crop insurance
program structured adequately to reflect
what we thought was going to be a set of
increased risks of failure and you know
were they prepared for that so it
actually stimulated a whole set of
thinking that that they hadn't really
appreciated before but it didn't have
the sort of broad national attention
that that the first National Climate
Assessment did or the subsequent
National Climate assessments have either
had or are meant to have the second
report largely summarized the work of
this whole series of individual topical
reports that had been commissioned
and although it started in the in the
tail end of the Bush administration it
was endorsed and officially released by
the White House and the first Obama
administration and and and in in my
sense I view that is actually a major
plus that a signal that that the the
scientific assessment process was viewed
to be nonpartisan to the extent that
even though it had begun in a previous
political administration it could it was
still embrace and released and endorsed
by a very different administration it
was touted by the officials who released
it as a game changer but I think we'd
all be forgiven if we were to ask if
that has really been true and we're now
in the middle of a third national
climate assessment which repeats many of
the features of the first one a large a
very large investment in stakeholder
consultation and stakeholder engagement
a whole series of both sectoral and
regional reports of topical reports that
are being incorporated into a set into a
synthesis document and interestingly for
the first time in the US National
Assessments we're finally addressing the
issue of mitigation directly as opposed
to the previous assessments which dealt
with it not at all we finally have one
chapter out of 30 devoted to mitigation
so the the balance of innocence the
science the balance of this particular
science that has been chosen to be
addressed and started to swing a little
bit in a sense from the opposite
perspective of the IPCC which is was
focused very early on the on the on the
physical sciences a large effort on
mitigation decisions and has sort of
slowly been trying to to really work on
adaptation issues the US assessment is
is sort of in a very
different trajectory so these national
efforts have some some interesting
similarities to IPCC this notion of
consensus seeking specific attempts to
summarize things for policy audiences
but also something that's some quite
significant differences this focus
almost entirely on impacts and climate
science that it's important for impacts
very little attention to mitigation
until just recently much more effort to
engage broad communities of stakeholders
in local state and regional discussions
and try to understand what are the
issues that are important to them so
that we can actually structure the
scientific assessment in a sense around
those issues but their national
influence is I think tempered greatly by
the polarization of the political
discussion of climate change and and
it's an open question I think how many
of these factors will change for the for
the third for the third national climate
assessment I actually on the train ride
up this morning I been emailing with a
with a colleague who also worked on the
first and the second National Climate
Assessment sand I told her I said well
I'm going to go give this talk at
Columbia so here's the general thesis
about it and so she emailed back and
said well are we are we going to be a
success or a failure this time so it
beats me I guess we'll find out so the
last thing I want to do is is is take
some of these observations about
assessment processes and think about
some lessons for the future because I
think this kind of this kind of
communications approaches with us to
stay and it's important I think to to
now to start to think through how we
might want to construct these processes
in a way that the assessments have a
well-understood role to play that they
and then we recognize what they've done
well and what they haven't done well and
in some extent they've done really well
in characterizing what's known to some
extent there there there there a little
more challenge with characterizing
what's uncertain
and and and so just as an example one of
the key findings from the last national
climate assessment is this notion that
thresholds are going to be crossed
leading to large changes in climate and
ecosystems and we can actually be quite
confident about that because we're
starting to see empirical evidence of
this in today's world this is just one
example of these sort of vast
infestations of bark beetles this
happens to be spruce bark beetle in
Alaska that are far outside at any
historical precedent or that climate
change is an interactive process it will
interact with many other social and
environmental stresses changes in energy
demand the interactions of water
shortages and the need for cooling water
for thermoelectric electricity
production but we also have to recognize
that these these processes are about
more than simply the science we don't
always do as well putting these major
scientific issues into a broader context
or in expanding the scientific agenda or
the assessment agenda away from the sort
of is it happening to how well do we
understand potential responses and the
constant consequences of potential
responses or for all the attention that
we focus on it I think we've yet to
really grapple with this notion about
the importance and influence of
uncertainty and and I say this with some
trepidation because every one of these
processes whether its domestic or
international always starts with this
very vigorous debate about the
importance and crucial nature of
communicating uncertainty to the policy
audiences and in some in some sense i
think we've kind of erected this
monument to the importance of
uncertainty and decision making but the
fact is that we deal with uncertainty
and we decide anyway we do this all the
time and so i'm going to i'm going to
use i'm going to take a little bit of a
digression and talk about uncertainty
using an example that some of you are
the beneficiaries of and some of you are
wrestling with right now and that is how
do you save for college right because
one thing you have to understand the
nature and the size of the problem
are you thinking about in-state tuition
out-of-state tuition private tuition for
years or more how many kids are you
trying to put through what's your goal
full support half the cost of tuition
you know are you just starting now so
for those of you on this side of the
room that's that's probably a salient
question you know and then what are the
implications you know can you afford to
send that second kid what about other
things in your life that you also value
going on vacation buying a car the whole
range of things you know we solve these
kinds of problems all the time without
being able to predict the precise future
of our investments because we know how
to think about them we know how to hedge
our bets or at least we learn how to
hedge our bets we don't let the we don't
let the presence the inevitable presence
of uncertainty about the future whether
it's the longer-range feature or the
shorter range future paralyze us in
terms of important life decisions and
there's no particular reason why
uncertainty in these difficult
environmental issues should paralyze us
from appropriate decision making so my
last set of recommendations I think our
focus our focus primarily on climate but
i think these can be more general as
well and in some sense we want to look
for the integration a different
disciplinary perspective more
appreciation for the actual range of
decisions that will be considered and
how to approach these questions of
interactions with other policy issues so
for example the scientific assessment
processes both in the US and
internationally have mostly not ask the
question is climate the biggest factor
to deal with and this has led I think
that some significant misunderstandings
in both directions thinking thinking
that climate is a really big factor when
it's not and thinking that climate is
unimportant when it's not the time scale
is a phenomena that we were concerned
about matter great deal in this if you
think about water resources and drought
the sort of what do you do about
managing the dam next week on to to
assure that you have continuity of flow
for thermal
electric generation in a sense is not a
climate problem it's a weather problem
and you know we have a lot of experience
for how to deal with that dealing with
the effects of persistent interannual
historic levels of drought in the u.s.
Southwest is absolutely a climate
problem our institutions are not set up
to deal with that very well they're
inflexible and we're failing at that and
that is part of the channel i part of
why climate is a challenge in the sort
of this differentiation between weather
challenges and long-term climate
challenges the second thing is that
adaptation matters the typical these
typical assessments have investigated
impacts saans adaptation in a sense of
sensitivity analysis how sensitive are
agricultural systems or crop production
to changes in the climate world but in
the real world adaptation matters a lot
we can we have examples from health
risks or in fact an individual cities
heatwave mortality declines over time
even even with the same degree of a
meteorological event because people
learn there's institutional learning
there's individual learning as
institutional learning there's
preparation for the next event we've
seen the same thing in coastal risks um
where we've got this vast exposure of
infrastructure but in some cases the
hardening of defenses and we see the
same thing typically in agricultural
systems with changes in management
strategies crop breeding and so on we
should in fact have a new generation of
assessments that begins to incorporate
these human adaptation responses as more
than simply an assessment of the
physical science by itself so we should
be moving away from sensitivity analyses
and improving our abilities to
characterize risks on this interannual
to the cattle timescales if we have some
availability of adaptation options how
much influence or additional damage does
climate change actually have
what's the sort of marginal increase or
decrease in risk from climate change
where are their trade-offs between
mitigation decisions and adaptation
decisions what trade-offs for example
are inherent in decisions to promote the
use of by purpose grown bioenergy crops
for stars for storing carbon on
landscapes which is by far the cheapest
way to store carbon the physical the
physical science is going to remain
important but it's difficult in the
short to medium term because of the
influence of natural variability
downscaling this notion that that we
have we we have this desire to say
something concrete about changes in the
climate system for New York or New York
state as opposed to North America or the
northern hemisphere is going to remain a
difficult physical and statistical
challenge so we might for example argue
that instead of the sort of predict then
act model we move towards a model that
we consider a range of actions and and
evaluate which of those potential
choices is robust to our scientific
uncertainty in how the climate system
will evolve but the climate future we
get also depends on how much forcing
there actually is so this challenge of
energy choices and mitigation choices is
it is and how development works is
enormously important we can't know this
right but so we have to model it and
here I think increasing sophistication
and how we think about scenarios and the
use of scenarios to span uncertainty in
in structure the way we think about the
future will in fact become more
important rather than less in my view so
these processes will be the most useful
I think when they really come to grips
with a singular reality about scientific
assessment these are communication
activities in a risk management and
decision-making context and that they
focus on the important thing
not just that the sign has sharp edges
but that the bridge is out I had thank
you thank you for joining us here I have
a specific question with regards to the
first national assessment I was
wondering what were the reasons for why
it was there was such a push towards
limiting its it's doubled ins I'm sorry
for limiting its if we're why the
administration at the time was was so
Bay him and not getting it out was it
for political reasons well I mean I
won't make a political judgment there
was a dramatic change in
administration's you know and in their
approach towards environmental issues
the arm it was also and so I think the
the the the dimensions of those
arguments had already become polar
really quite polarized in ways that that
other environmental issues had largely
not been right it was this was really
sort of a political battlefield and I
think for those of us in a scientific
community who participated in that
assessment we found ourselves just you
know talk about deer in the headlights I
mean I think we found ourselves just
sort of in some sense sort of baffled
when you know why were these yr were
these people saying such horrible things
about us and why was I getting emails
that I couldn't show my mother and um
and and partly I think that's the stakes
are the states were really high the
stakes are high partly because there was
also this ongoing a sort of virulent
policy debate about what to do about the
Kyoto Protocol this was also exactly the
same time as the US was was in the
middle of negotiating in Kyoto and you
know so there was a sort of one theory
that the whole assessment process was in
a sense sort of cooked up to provide the
fear factor to get the u.s. to agree to
Kyoto
if that was the case nobody ever told us
um but but you know there were people
who really strongly believe that ah and
you know and i think it was i think when
your face for that kind of polarization
it's really hard to convince people that
you're not part of that discussion you
really are just trying to shed shed some
light on sort of the underlying
principles thank you i was just curious
if there has been moving from you know
i'm thinking out in political science
and the study of commissions as an idea
generally commissions are received
historically in this society and of the
society is sort of like here we have a
ruler to a problem and then it sort of
diffused where it can be looked on as
sort of a stopgap measure politically
and when you look at all these different
studies some of which i've read i wonder
how and what your thoughts are how
they've actually been dimensionalized in
public opinion concretely in the
different phases they've actually been
put out is it just elite public opinion
because usually when you deal with
foreign policy issues we've done when i
was taught 30 40 years ago only ten
percent of population pay attention
perhaps only less than one or two or
three percent pay attention to this so
I'm just wondering how that's evolved in
practical terms in mask opinion with
these kind of policy studies and in our
country is their regional variations of
this they're clearly regional variations
the we saw a lot of this actually in the
in the run-up to the first National
Climate Assessment where we did I think
22 workshops all around the country it
was absolutely fascinating and we didn't
start the workshops by saying you know
we want to talk about climate change we
started all the workshops by saying we
want to talk about the issues that are
important to you in at least the
environmental issues that are important
to you in your part of the your part of
the world your
of the country and then use that as a
springboard to identify whether or not
climate change was important in that
context or potentially important in that
context if had we started the discussion
with climate change I think we knew
perfectly well what would it happens we
would have had half the audience would
it just switched off and the other half
would have been on top of us for you
know why aren't you just talking about
choose your favorite response
cap-and-trade carbon taxes that we'd
already we were already at this sort of
polarization point I don't know whether
or not you know whether or not the
public reaction to these various
assessment reports is sort of equivalent
to you know sort of high-level
Commission personally I hadn't thought
about it quite that way before the I do
know that particularly when IPCC reports
come out with there is often sort of a
bump in the sort of attention being paid
to global change issues climate change
issues what is also true is you get a
bump when you get a weather disasters it
was a huge bump after sandy there's a
huge bump after major heat waves ization
you know there's a lot of you know the
big fires that are in Colorado right now
you know I bet you that there's a bump
in Colorado after those fires go through
and so whether or not that's persistent
is not so clear you know but one thing
that is persistent is is the in a sense
the importance of the issue the public
attention to it will wax and wane but
this is truly a long-term issue that we
are going to be grappling with for
decades
hello so you talked a little bit about
adaptation and the possible ways that
cities around the world are doing this
already but how would cities like New
York or along the east coast adapt to
extreme weather events like sandy or a
change or loss of biodiversity and areas
such as Amazon and where people's are
extremely dependent on their ecosystem
so actually New York has one of the best
articulated and most complete adaptation
plans of any major city in the u.s. they
spend it they spend a lot of time on it
looking primarily at the sort of the
major pieces of infrastructure there are
sort of known sensitivities the subways
already flood in a big you know in a big
persistent thunderstorm so it's not it's
not you know in the city has started to
try to figure out okay so what are we
going to do about this as the climate
system continues to change Boston is
doing the same thing Boston actually
started doing that when they rebuilt the
Deer Island sewage treatment plant they
built it about I don't know three feet
higher than they had originally planned
the marginal cost of doing that is nil
it's just small small small compared to
the overall cost of the project but it
was support it was clearly a protective
feature in some sense one of the
adaptation challenges for cities
especially here I mean in the u.s. is
that especially in the East is we have
these old industrial cities where this
infrastructure is going to sort of going
to be in this turnover phase anyway and
so when you've got the opportunity what
do you do what's the right thing to do
and I think that does provide some
opportunities for the cities to do some
creative things looking forward
curious about the global biodiversity
assessment I have two questions about it
one what prompted these scientific
communities two together this
independent assessment in the first
place and second maybe can't be answered
until the next such effort comes out but
what do you suppose they might have
taken our learn from the fact that they
just did not make the splash that they
were hoping for well I think that I
think the answer the first one is that
we're in the middle of the biggest
extinction event sort of the sixth major
extinction event there's no great you
know it's not a meat-eor this time it's
not it's not lava traps you know it's us
we're doing it all right background
extinction rates or current extinction
rates for for flora and fauna that we
know about or sort of on order a
thousand time higher thousand times
higher than recent background it's no
great mystery why and and so and I said
there's been a long-standing concern in
the scientific communities even outside
of the conservation communities that
this is not a sustainable pattern and
that that there should be you know that
people need to understand sort of a need
for understanding this and also a need
for really understanding what's
impossible responses to it are so that
you know in a sense that's that's sort
of this is sort of the simplest possible
motivation that that there was not a
broad appreciation of the magnitude of
the changes involved and not a broad
appreciation of the sorts of things that
might might be done answer what was the
scientific basis and so on I think that
a lot of lessons were actually we're
learned by the participants and the
leadership of that of that assessment
and in particular about the importance
of engaging sort of more coherent policy
audiences as the assessments are
undertaken I think the big challenge in
the global biodiversity assessment was
the
you know in a very real sense nobody
asked for it except us and so when we
when we finished you know we had that we
had the staff and the secretariat of the
major convention who were really excited
about it but not not necessarily the
participating countries and so i think
there's a lesson there there's a lesson
there about global governance
environmental governance is a lesson
there about the both the opportunities
and the limits of engaging the actual
decision making communities or
institutions beforehand we'll see if
we've learned our lesson actually have
another question about a both of those
assessments you know the GBA and the
Emmy a commoner and wondering sort of
you know it's part of the kind of
salience on a global level from
something like the IPCC the fact that
like a lot of this evidence is coming
from things like GCMs but the very
nature of ecology is such that a you
know as practice as the science you know
with the scaling issues over time and
space where you can't really come up
with that kind of global evidence and a
true kind of compilation of you know
current knowledge is going by definition
to be a sort of real hodgepodge I think
there's some of that I don't think
that's I don't think that's a sufficient
explanation though you know because the
certainly the trends for reductions are
trade-offs in either in ecosystem
services or in the loss of diversity are
in fact global trends I mean they're
they're globally important phenomena
there's a handful of major causes I
think that I do think that the
scientific communities the structure of
the scientific communities who are sort
of primarily engaged in the other hand
it very very different and so those of
us who are trained as ecologists
weren't necessarily originally trained
to think of these as has sort of global
you know what sorts of global trends are
out there and how would you analyze them
and what do you think about you know
what do you think about them it's just
sort of not outside of the of the
training envelope or at least it was
less so now I think I think there's more
appreciation both in the scientific
community about how important some of
these larger scale patterns actually are
I've got a question about how you
characterize the policy community so is
there ever talk about trying to really
reach beyond like I'd say the typical
policy community to groups like I think
other other organizations like from
unions community organizations religious
organizations and I mean like I guess
are people talking about doing that and
if so what kinds of challenges with that
entail people do it I mean this is one
of the big differences between the US
National Assessments and the
International IPCC process the IPCC
process is a governmentally driven
process right so national governments
come almost nobody else counts the other
other or kinds of organizations have
their influence in the framework
convention in the political discussions
but not in the scientific assessment the
on the other hand for the US National
Climate Assessment there's been a very
large effort to engage a whole variety
of other sorts of communities and other
sorts of audiences local governments
state governments regional compacts NGOs
faith-based groups scientific societies
some of that is for sort of
dissemination of the of the message some
of that is to actually understand what
their concerns are and sort of in a
sense what their menu of actions are
that that might require some
illumination
you know where the scientific community
can actually be helpful so it's a very
it's a very different atmosphere than
the IPCC
as the scientific community starts to
shift the conversation more towards
adaptation what segments of the academic
community and what industries within the
private sector seemed to be most
responsive to that shift and most
willing to engage in that conversation
the the it I think that shift has really
highlighted a weakness in many of the
underlying research programs the the
importance of the social sciences and
economics on the to dealing with
adaptation topics is is in a sense it's
hard to overestimate and there we really
don't I think have enough people
involved in understanding those issues
whether it's sort of institutional
change or sort of the economy even just
the economics of adaptation the you know
it's been quite interesting to see you
know sort of which of the private sector
communities you know I've kind of jumped
first right because they're still not
surprisingly i think a lot of the
private sector interest on climate
change issues has revolved around the
energy sector understandably but one of
the really fascinating features about
the energy sector of course is that it
you know there's a lot of fixed
infrastructure and so you know katrina
got a lot of attention not just because
of New Orleans but because it
interrupted supplies of natural gas for
a seat into the US for a significant
period of time and the fate of all that
of all those Derrick's in the Gulf you
know there's maintenance involved those
operations involved what do you how do
you how did the big energy companies
start to think about that well this is
looking at the energy sector not as a
driver of climate change but as a
recipient and
impacts of climate change it's been
we've actually focused a fair deal on
that a fair amount on that in this third
National Climate Assessment you know
we're sort of impacts on energy is
starting out to be really important and
quite interesting feature of the report
you began your discussion with the issue
of uncertainty and when I've listened to
scholars who are from different
disciplines talking about climate change
uncertainty is something they accept
that sort of part of the scholarly
discourse but unfortunately when you
communicate that to the public and to
elect officials they jump on it that's
like the barn door open let's yeah drive
through um so how do you bridge that gap
because it's perfectly reasonable to
talk about uncertainty but then on the
other hand if you're dealing with people
who have limited resources and doing
analyses of policy choices ABCD where to
put money well they can sit there and
hammer the uncertainty issue and and and
I'm just curious because as a
communication question general it
doesn't resonate with people if they can
then take uncertainty and then discredit
the analysis that's very deep and now
this case makes it sound like we don't
know anything and so why should we make
big decisions if you don't know anything
and I wouldn't make big decisions if I
didn't know anything either so I it's
it's it's I wish they were really easy
answered that question the what a lot of
what a lot of us who've been involved in
these processes try to do is to be
honest about where the uncertainty is
and what kind of uncertainty it is so
for example I do a lot of sort of public
talks on climate change issues and I
talk about change in the atmosphere
changing the atmospheric composition
where does this extra co2 come from you
know because there's essentially no
uncertainty about that we've known since
about nineteen fifty-five where the
extra co2 comes from you know
it's extremely well documented the fact
of the greenhouse effect is is you know
sort of this is beyond serious question
so there are elements of the climate
change issue of for which there is
really very little uncertainty there are
other elements in which there is a
tremendous I'll use a very quality
determine Mendes out of uncertainty and
the challenge i think is teasing out the
parts that matter in the parts that
don't you know does it matter for for
the policy making or decision making
that that no one is going to be able to
give you a weather forecast for 20 30 50
for eastern Long Island they're just not
you will get people who will tell you
they can do that but they can't and they
won't there's just sort of mathematical
limits to predictability and and on the
other hand do you really need that to
make those decisions if you had that
information would you actually be able
to use it and in many cases the answer
that is no and so I think part of the
challenges being sensible about which
parts of this uncertainty the spectrum
of uncertainties actually is relevant to
the decision making at hand because
otherwise I mean you're right it can be
used as a crutch well these guys are
they aren't sure so we're not going to
decide Tony I have a question and you
clearly showed us how climate time
scales and especially ecosystem time
scales are really quite different than
weather event timescales political time
scales and this issue attention cycle
which can be extremely short so that's
one issue is the incommensurability
somehow and how to bring that into
conversation the other one is the we're
going to hear in the future some some of
our evening speakers will be talking
about
the polarization of climate discourse
and and and some might even talk about a
bipartisan way forward but we have 190
nations or more and we have a really an
international issue here we'll also hear
about methodological best science
multidisciplinary but we also know that
we need all of our disciplines to
address these issues and ultimately it
be even becomes beyond disciplines into
a human behavior and existence problem
so all this is kind of a long it's kind
of a long-winded way of setting you up
to discuss your vision of the party
center not only the longer future but
the timescales of the longer feature and
the way forward which was some of your
ending slides about the way forward how
do you you know and what is the vision
of going from these assessments which
are often domestic whether they're often
best science multidisciplinary and so
you know it's a softball question but
I'd like to hear the vision of what is
the big way forward well I mean let me
narrow that a little bit at least talk
about the party center so so the party
center has this has this you know sort
of interesting interesting title of the
study of the longer-range feature but
but i think you know sort of underneath
that is the concern with changes that we
see in societies both in physical
environment and the cultural environment
and the social and economic environments
that occur over these certain time
scales of several decades you know sort
of out to a century and and part of the
reason that that time scale is is so
interesting and so difficult is that a
lot of the institutions that we have are
really well constructed to deal with
problems over those scales so if you
think about about issues that are
totally outside of the realm of science
physical science
I don't you know completely outside i
like the future of the Social Security
trust fund right is it is a sort of an
inevitable function of demographics that
that that we're going to be supporting a
growing number of retirees with a
smaller number of workers that's a
problem that's you know in a sense it's
arithmetic and look how long we've been
discussing that problem in our in our
institutions without really making much
of a dent on it and so I just I'll just
use that as sort of emblematic of the
kinds of changes in the world that are
that we can see happening we can see
them starting to unfold but
understanding their understanding their
consequences and understanding the range
of potential solutions turns out to be
quite difficult the other kinds of
issues that at least I see is being
particularly important for for a center
like the party center are the challenges
that in the interrelationships between
developing the developing world and the
industrialized world now we are headed
for a world with nine billion people
maybe 10 we don't know how to feed that
world most of those people are not going
to live here they're going to be in very
large cities in urban areas mostly in
the developing world how do we think
about a world like that you know this is
a this a very different world then
then we have today but in a sense it's
it's the it's the further elaboration of
trends that we can already start to see
unfolding and yet you know we have
choices ahead of us and so I think one
of the one of the really important
things that a place like party can do is
to start to understand the both the
single disciplines and in a multi
multidisciplinary way what do those
choices look like how well do we
understand them what are the forces at
work do we understand what interventions
might be might be sensible what their
consequences are I don't we run a
graduate as a graduate seminar much as
you're doing during the summer and one
of the things that we told the students
just a couple of weeks ago was that part
of the challenge of thinking about these
kinds of issues in this
interdisciplinary way is that what
you're really doing is you're
recognizing the problems the way the
world presents the world doesn't present
us with problems that are okay here's
one for the biologists here's one for
the sociologists here's one for the
economist and you guys all go off and
play and come back when you're done and
tell us what the answers were it's not
the way we get them you know week
they're messy kind of bleed into each
other they require multiple perspectives
simply to understand much less to try to
help people think about potential path
forward cool well I for one hope to take
the Downeaster to visit you would be
let's thank our guests thank you
you